So let's say that we're going
to play repeated trading games,
and if you're a very agreeable,
then you're going to
bargain harder on my behalf,
bargain on your own behalf.
Whereas if you're very disagreeable,
you're going to do the reverse.
You're going to think,
I mean this trading game for me and
you are going to take care of your own
interests where an agreeable
person is going to say no,
no,
at best this is at worst,
this has to be 50 50 but I'd
like to help you every way I can.
Okay,
now the credit,
okay,
so you Kinda,
you kinda understand that.
Now the advantage to being agreeable
then is that you're good in teams and
you're very much likely to give
other people credit that bad.
The downside of being agreeable is that
you're not very good at putting forward
your own interests.
And so one of the things that
predicts salary across time,
for example,
is agreeableness.
And it predicts it negatively.
And so it's part of the reason
why women get paid less than men.
And this is something for the women in
the class to really listen to because
you,
how you get paid across time depends
on a very large number of things,
right?
It depends on your skills
and your abilities and your
position and your social
network and all of that,
but the other thing it depends on is
whether or not you actually go ask for
money or maybe that you don't even ask
because actually you don't ask for money.
You tell people that you need to be paid
more or something they don't like will
happen and I don't mean as a threat.
I mean that you have to be willing
when you're negotiating to have an
alternative,
you go talk to your boss who isn't
going to give you money because everyone
wants money,
right?
It's a competitive game.
You're going to have to be,
you're going to have to go there and say,
look,
here's what I do.
Here's why it's useful.
Here's why you have to give me more
money and this is by opportunities.
If you don't,
and then you're not taking your boss's
money anyways because it's very seldom,
very frequently the case that he's
working for a whopping big company,
but he needs an excuse to give you money
because everyone's asking for money all
the time.
And so you have to put your case
forward powerfully and disagreeable.
Now,
you don't want to do it to disagree and
bleed because then he's going to think
that you're a son of a bin.
Maybe he's not going to give you anything,
and maybe you'll get fired for
being mouthy and all of that.
And that certainly happens to
people who are too disagreeable.
You got to get the balance right,
but it's definitely the case.
And the other thing that happens
to women that's also worth noting,
and this is probably because
they're higher negative emotion,
is they tend to underestimate their
own utility in business settings,
right?
Because if you're trying to evaluate
what you're like and you're more tilted
towards negative emotion than the things
that you do that are wrong are going to
stand out more,
more on the foreground and the
things that you do that are right.
So if you go into a negotiation and
you're uncertain already because you have
self doubts and then you're
agreeable in the negotiation,
what's going to happen is that
you're not going to win as often.
And winning in in a business setting or
in a career development setting means
more opportunity for promotion
and more revenue generated.
Now the downside of that,
of course,
is as you climb the business hierarchies
that you also have to take on more
responsibility.
And that responsibility is
sometimes unpleasant as well,
especially to people who are agreeable
because you're not necessarily liked if
you're in a position of authority and
agreeable people really like to be liked.
It's their primary motive motivator
because they're concerned about the
maintenance,
I would say,
of of,
of,
of intimate positive relationships.
But that also makes
them conflict avoidant.
Okay.
So now you guys can think about this,
but,
but I'll,
I'll tell you why.
I think the personality differences
between men and women exist now,
these are speculative hypotheses,
but they're reasonably well documented by,
by the relevant literature.
So let's,
let's think about it.
The first thing we might think about is
what's the difference between men and
women?
Well,
how do they differ?
the first thing we might observe is that
if you look at personality differences
between p pre pubescent boys and girls,
they're not very large.
Boys and girls don't
differ in terms of their,
their trait neuroticism,
for example.
What happens is that
when puberty kicks in,
women's trait neuroticism rises and it
stays higher than men for the rest of
their life.
And this is why you see this reflected
in the different kinds of psychopathology
that be set,
the two sexist.
So men are overrepresented in alcoholism,
drug abuse,
antisocial personality,
and a host of learning disorders as
well as add attention deficit disorder.
And women are overrepresented in
depression and anxiety primarily.
That seems to be tightly associated
with higher levels of trait neuroticism
because maybe it's if you're at
the 95th percentile or higher,
let's say in trait neuroticism,
there isn't much different than difference
between that and being somewhat prone
to depression and anxiety.
And because the curves overlap,
you know,
th th th the curves aren't identical.
The normal distributions are
identical for men and women.
You tilt the one to the,
to the right,
to the women's curve,
to the right towards higher
levels of neuroticism.
You go out,
you look for the person in 20 who has
the highest levels of negative emotion,
it's much more likely
to be female than male.
Okay,
so let's see if we can figure out why.
So we're going to tell you some things,
basic differences between men and women.
And you can tell me what you
think about it if you are,
if you agree or disagree.
Okay.
First size differential emerges
between men and women at puberty,
right?
Because boys and girls are roughly the
same size and roughly the same strength.
But men get bigger at puberty
when the testosterone kicks in.
And more importantly,
not only do they get taller and heavier,
but their upper body
strength is much higher.
And that's a real issue for for
combat because human beings punch.
There's other animals that do that.
Kangaroos do that two ways.
So we're not the,
we're not the only people that punch,
but we have clubs on the ends of our arms.
So That's interesting.
So okay,
so there's a bar,
there's a body size difference that's
important to strength differential,
that's important.
Next thing I think.
So let's assume that the reason that women
are higher in sensitivity to negative
emotion is because the world is
actually more dangerous to women.
I think that women's nervous
systems are not adapted to women.
I think women's nervous systems are
adapted to the mother infant dyad.
And because you are not the same
creature when you have an infant,
not at all,
you're way more vulnerable.
And it's partly because you have to
express their vulnerability of the infant
and you also have to care for it.
Right?
So you think about an infant,
especially under nine months.
So let's say,
how are you going to be wired up if you're
going to optimally care for an infant
under nine months?
And I'm saying under nine months,
because women generally do the bulk of
childcare for infants who are under nine
months old.
And part of the reason for that,
there's a whole host of reasons,
but part of the reasons for that
obviously is that they breastfeed.
But imagine what you need to be wired
up biologically in order to care for an
infant.
First of all,
they're very demanding,
right?
Because they're completely helpless and
they're demanding 24 hours a day and
it's quite,
uh,
emotional load.
And an infant under nine
months is never wrong,
right?
What you do to an infant under nine
months is when they're in distress,
you always respond.
You never tell the infant,
get your act together and stop whining,
right?
Which you can do,
say to an end,
to a child that's 18 months old,
you can start having that
sort of conversation,
but under nine months it's like
nothing is the infant's fault.
It's surrounded in an
extraordinarily threatening world.
And you have to be responsive to what
it needs regardless of what you want.
And you have to be very sensitive
to the threats that emerged in the
environment.
And so I think the price that women pay
for that ability to have an intimate
relationship with infants in the very
earliest stages of development is that
their nervous systems are actually
wired so that they can perform that role
optimally.
And the disadvantage to that
is that having a temperament
like that doesn't work
that well when you're
dealing with adult men,
especially when you're dealing with them
and in a business environment because
it's not the same thing.
Not at all.
It's a competitive environment.
So,
okay,
so agreeable people are
compassionate and polite.
What are disagreeable people like?
They're tough minded.
They're blunt,
they're competitive,
and they won't do a damn
thing they don't want to do.
So it isn't exactly
that they're aggressive,
although they will push you the hell
out of their way if you're in the way.
They're not.
They're not like volatile like you are.
If you're high in neuroticism,
it isn't defensive aggression.
It's more like predatory aggression.
It's dominance behavior.
And so for someone who's high,
who's high,
highly disagreeable,
they look at the world as a place
in which they can compete and win.
And I'll tell you a story,
I have a friend,
I gave him my personality test,
the Big Five aspects scale that Colin
de Young developed tongue in my lab.
And uh,
I knew he is a disagreeable guy
and by interacting with them,
I mean he's even rude to people
sort of spontaneously on the street.
I actually liked them quite a bit.
He's very,
very funny.
He's also very conscientious
so you can trust them,
but it's disagreeable as hell.
And uh,
so I gave him this task because I thought
it would be funny and he came out as
the most disagreeable person in 10,000
so reasonably reasonable in compassion,
both 30th percentile but
like 0.001 in politeness.
So he's extraordinarily blunt and
he'll just say absolutely anything,
no matter how horrible it is.
And he was often brought into
corporations to sort of clean them up.
So if a corporation was
tilting and not doing well,
they bring him in to find out how
the useless people were in fire them.
And I talked to him about that because
I've had the miss opportunity to have to
not have graduate students in my lab,
for example,
that weren't performing well.
And I'd find it very,
very difficult to,
you know,
dress someone down and certainly
difficult to fire them.
I just hate it because I'm
actually quite an agreeable person,
much to my chagrin.
And I asked him about that and I said,
well,
what do you do?
You have to fire people all the time.
How do you handle out?
He says,
handle it.
I enjoy it.
And I thought,
wow,
that's so interesting that
someone would have that response.
I said,
well,
what do you mean you enjoy it?
He said,
look,
I go into these companies and I analyze
the performance of groups of people,
right?
And there's in those groups,
there are people who are really striving,
really trying hard and working themselves
really hard and being productive.
And then there's these people
that are just doing nothing.
They're completely in the way.
They don't carry their weight at all.
They take advantage every chance they get.
And they're always whining
about why they can't work.
It's like I find out who they are and
call them into my office and I tell them
exactly what they've been doing.
It's like hit the road buddy.
You've had your,
you've had your run of it.
And I thought,
Oh yeah,
okay,
fair enough.
You know?
Well,
I can tell you,
you know,
I've had situations in my lab where I
had underperforming graduate students and
one of the things that was really awful
about that was that it was really hard
on the high performing graduate students,
you know,
because they felt that even being in the
same category as the people who weren't
working hard and pulling their
weight devalued what they were doing.
You know?
And that's exactly right.
And so this is also why there's,
there is a conscientiousness trait
and it agreeableness trait because
conscientious people judge
you on your accomplishments,
right?
They don't give a damn
about your feelings,
not a bit.
It's like,
are you doing the work or not?
Whereas agreeable people think,
well,
you know,
your mother is sick and you know you've,
you've got a bunch of family problems and
we all have to take care of each other
and it's no wonder that
you're having a rough time.
And like you can't say that one of
those attitudes is correct and the other
isn't correct.
You can't say that.
There wouldn't be those two dimensions
if there wasn't something correct about
both of them.
But you can certainly point
out that often they conflict,
you know,
and so the demand for,
for inclusiveness and unity and care and
the demand for high level performance
in a hierarchical structure,
they're very different
orientations in the world.
And so it's complicated for people
who are agreeable and conscientious.
And actually I think often that
large corporations and large,
large institutions of any sort run on
the unheralded labor of people who are
high in agreeableness and high
in conscientiousness and they're
disproportionately women in my
experience in large institutions,
has been that if you want to hire
someone to exploit appropriately,
not appropriately,
if you wanted to hire someone
to exploit productively,
you higher middle aged women who are
hyper conscientious and who are agreeable
because they'll do everything.
They won't take credit for
it and they won't complain.